el cursor es hora de tomar una decisión
que llega con retraso de reconocer
inmediatamente la independencia y la
soberanía de las repúblicas populares de
donets y lugar mary's publicó el anuncio
de vladimir putin no es el primero de
este tipo es la tercera vez que rusia
reconoce oficialmente la independencia
de un territorio que hacía parte de las
15 repúblicas de la antigua unión
soviética
territorios nacidos del conflicto con el
poder central y reconocido solo por muy
pocos países entre ellos rusia
este es el caso de osetia del sur
para la comunidad internacional es parte
de georgia
pero la republica tiene fronteras un
presidente una bandera y sus propias
instituciones en 1992 la región se
declaró independiente tras un referendo
en 2008 estalló una guerra de cinco días
con georgia rusia intervino y se llegó a
un acuerdo de paz moscú reconoció
entonces la independencia de osetia del
sur
para la alegría de sus habitantes
a asia es otra parte de georgia
respaldada por el kremlin el territorio
de ocho mil seiscientos kilómetros
cuadrados entre el cáucaso y el mar
negro también proclamó su independencia
en un referendo en
1999 que fue considerado ilegal por las
naciones unidas pero el 26 de agosto de
2008 el mismo día en que reconoció a
osetia del sur moscú también declaró la
independencia de abjasia otra zona
progresa entre moldavia y ucrania
transmitiría en 1992 la región declaró
su independencia esta vez rusia no la
respaldó al menos no oficialmente pero
su política y economía están muy
influenciadas por moscú quien también
proporciona apoyo militar protegiendo el
territorio con al menos 1000 soldados
30 años después de la caída de la unión
soviética esta franja de europa del este
sigue siendo el patio trasero de moscú